en el vídeo titulado completando el
cuadrado estuve diciendo que todo lo que
es la ecuación cuadrática es completar
esencialmente un binomio cuadrado o
mejor dicho un atajo para completar el
cuadrado y tenía la impresión de que
había hecho esta demostración
anteriormente pero ahora me doy cuenta
de que no lo había hecho así que déjenme
demostrarles la ecuación cuadrática
completando el cuadrado digamos que
tengo una ecuación cuadrática muy en
general digamos que esto es a x cuadrada
+ b x + c igual a 0 esta es una ecuación
cuadrática muy en general y por supuesto
voy a suponer que está este número a
pues no es 0 porque si fuera 0 esto ya
no aparece y me queda una ecuación
lineal y no me interesa ahorita resolver
ecuaciones lineales así que si tengo
esta ecuación cuadrática déjenme quitar
esta c de este lado y pasarla del lado
derecho simplemente tenemos a x cuadrada
más bx y si restamos se de ambos lados
me queda aquí que se cancela y acá me
queda menos
entonces como dije en el vídeo no nos
gusta en el vídeo de completando el
cuadrado no nos gusta tener una a que
esté al lado de la equis cuadrado de la
equis cuadrada entonces puedo dividir
entre esa y puedo dividir porque no es
cero entonces si dividimos entre esa lo
que nos va a quedar es x cuadrada + b /
a equis y déjenme dejar aquí un espacio
esto va a ser igual a menos c sobre a
muy bien simplemente lo que hice fue
dividir entre a de ambos lados ahora lo
que voy a hacer es completar el cuadrado
el binomio cuadrado es decir de este
lado izquierdo tengo algo de la forma x
cuadrada más algo x y yo voy a querer
sumarle algo aquí de tal suerte que lo
que me quede del lado izquierdo sea un
binomio al cuadrado es decir algo de la
forma x
al cuadrado y si recordamos muy bien qué
es eso de x más algo al cuadrado por
ejemplo tenemos x más a un numerito al
cuadrado esto es x cuadrada más dos
veces a x más
a cuadrada muy bien entonces yo
esencialmente lo que quiero hacer es
sumar algo aquí para que me quede de
esta forma que sea un binomio al
cuadrado y lo pueda yo factorizar de la
siguiente forma entonces qué es lo que
yo le tengo que sumar yo lo que tengo
que sumar es si nos damos cuenta 2a debe
ser de entre a quiere decir que este
número a es la mitad de b sobre a
entonces lo que yo voy a tener que hacer
es sumarle la mitad de b sobre a pero
debe ser al cuadrado verdad porque aquí
aparece al cuadrado entonces va a ser
vamos a sumar b sobre a y la mitad de
eso todo esto al cuadrado pero si lo
sume del lado izquierdo para que se
mantenga la igualdad debo sumarlo
también del lado derecho entonces esto
lo sumamos y ahí quedó entonces qué es
lo que obtuvimos obtuvimos que del lado
izquierdo justamente ya está expresado
de esta forma entonces puedo irme hacia
el lado izquierdo de esta igualdad esto
vamos a ver como x más la raíz cuadrada
del número que sume que es b sobre 2 a
todo esto al cuadrado verdad y eso será
igual a lo que me quedó del lado derecho
muy bien pero lo que me quedó del lado
derecho si por ejemplo simplificamos
esto de aquí esto es de cuadrada sobre 4
a cuadrada simplemente leve al cuadrado
el numerador y el denominador entonces
aquí es b cuadrada y 2 a todo eso al
cuadrado es 4a cuadrada entonces lo que
voy a hacer aquí es sacar un denominador
común que en este caso sería 4 a
cuadrada verdad porque 4a cuadrada es
divisible entre 4 al cuadrada y también
entre a muy bien entonces 4a cuadrada
entre a es 4a que si lo multiplicamos
por menos se me queda menos 4 a porsche
y luego 4 a cuadrada entre 4 a cuadrada
por b cuadrada simplemente es
de cuadrada verdad simplemente lo que
uno puede hacer es es distribuir esta
esta división ok ahora lo que voy a
hacer es tomar la raíz cuadrada de ambos
lados y si tomamos la raíz cuadrada de
ambos lados pues del lado izquierdo
simplemente se va a cancelar esto verdad
simplemente me queda x + b sobre 2a será
igual a la raíz cuadrada de este
cociente pero la raíz cuadrada de este
cociente es la raíz o el cociente de
cada una de las raíces entonces
simplemente va a ser tomar la raíz
cuadrada de simplemente voy a cambiar el
orden va a ser de cuadrada menos 4 hace
sobre la raíz cuadrada de 4 a cuadrada
que es 2a pero al tomar la raíz cuadrada
es importante que puede ser tanto la
positiva o la negativa tenemos dos
posibles valores que cumplen eso muy
bien entonces ya casi acabamos porque
vamos a tener que si restamos de ambos
lados b entre 2
vamos a tener que x es igual a b sobre
2a y aquí va a ser más o menos la raíz
cuadrada de de cuadrada menos 4 ac de
cuadrada menos 4 hacer sobre 2a muy bien
entonces como realmente tenemos el mismo
el mismo denominador podemos sumarlo
perfectamente y que es lo que obtenemos
que x es igual a b más o menos la raíz
de b
cuadrada menos 4 hace todo eso dividido
sobre 2
y esa esa es la famosa fórmula
cuadrática así que ahí ya lo tenemos ya
la demostramos y la demostramos sólo de
completar un cuadrado de en este lado
espero que esto les haya parecido algo
interesante nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo